Let's pray together over day 33, Roots and
Fruits in Our Lives.
Father, thank you for the joy that it is to have a heart that is
clean. Thank you, Lord, for the assurance that you
can take and bend our life and bend our
heart back straight to where we're not self-sovereign anymore.
We allow you to rule and reign as you
always are worthy of in our lives.
Lord, we want to live not just free of self-sovereign
nature of sin in a bent toward our own will and our own
way, but we want to live so that we are growing
past any areas of self-centeredness, any
unconscious ways of thinking,
cycles of automatic habitual behavior.
Lord, would you help us today to not get careless,
to not allow old ways of thinking, old patterns to
just hang around in our life,
but instead, oh God, would you sensitize us to the
presence of something that can lead to a life that
goes back to the way it used to be. Lord, would you help us to
be
so sensitive, so ready to hear that
like Charles Wesley wrote, we would have a
sensitivity to sin and a pain to feel it near.
Lord, would you give us a heart that is confident in what you have
done
but is passionate about growing what you have done as
well. Lord, help us to reprogram our minds, to reprogram
our hearts. We don't want old patterns to hang around and grow bitter
roots that bear bitter fruits. So instead, Lord, help
us to be able to ask, is it a root or is it a fruit?
And if it's a fruit, Lord, help us to have a heart of repentance, just to throw it
aside and to expect that you will give us exactly what we need
to grow in grace and holiness all the days of our life.
In Jesus' name, we ask these things.
Let's continue to pray together.